Facebook has 1.4 billion active users, that
means one-fifth of Earth's population has
a Facebook account.
Let's find out some mind-blowing facts about
the social networking giant.
1.
The average user spends 40 minutes a day on
Facebook.
2.
Some people spend so much time on Facebook
that there is actually a medically recognised
condition called FAD, or Facebook Addiction
Disorder, that is someone whom is wholly reliant
on Facebook and spends more than 3 hours on
it a day.
There are estimated to be around 350 million
people in the world unknowingly suffering
from Facebook Addiction Disorder.
A common symptom of FAD is adding complete
strangers as friends to artificially inflate
their friend count.
In fact research has shown that 80% of people
on the friends list of people who suffer from
FAD are fake friends.
3.
600,000 hacking attempts are made on Facebook
accounts every single day.
4.
Facebook will actually pay you if you successfully
hack their website and report the details
of your hack to Facebook.
This helps Facebook uncover bugs and fix security
holes before other hackers with more malicious
intentions find it and abuse it.
Facebook will pay you anywhere between $500
and $40,000 dollars if you can hack their
site.
5.
Al Pacino was the first ever face to appear
on Facebook, he appeared in the header of
the original website.
Nobody is really sure why Zuckerberg chose
Al Pacino.
6.
On average, every Facebook user is separated
by only 3.74 degrees of separation, from every
other Facebook user.
Or to put it another way, if you take any
other Facebook user in the world, they are
friends with someone who is friends with another
person, who is friends with someone else who
has a friend that is also a friend of yours.
7.
You can't block Mark Zuckerberg on Facebook.
Attempting to do so will display an error
message.
8.
The Facebook like button was originally going
to be called the "awesome" button.
9.
In 2005, Myspace was engaged in talks to buy
Facebook, but they rejected Mark Zuckerberg's
asking price of $75 million as too expensive.
10.
Facebook now brings in a colossal $3 billion
in revenue every quarter.
11.
Facebook has a whole 1 billion more users
than Twitter does.
12.
Amongst Facebook's huge feature set used to
be a peer-to-peer file-sharing service called
Wirehog.
When Facebook launched in 2004 users could
upload files to their account then share them
with their Facebook friends.
However Wirehog was eventually axed in 2006
due to security concerns.
13.
Similar to Google, Facebook employees get
three completely free meals a day as well
as free drinks.
Cooked by the self entitled "Facebook Culinary
Team".
There's actually a Facebook app to see what's
on the menu at the Facebook headquarters each
day, so Facebook employees don't even need
to leave their seats to order lunch.
It's called the "Lunchtime" app.
14.
Don't worry Facebook employees, if you get
fired from Facebook you can always sell your
hoodie.
A standard issue Facebook employee hoodie
sold on eBay for a whopping $4,050 with 50
bidders battling it out.
15.
But Facebook also has a few dark secrets.
Facebook tracks every site you visit, by using
JavaScript, iframes and cookies.
It can even track you when you're logged out.
This is how Facebook shows you ridiculously
accurate adverts, and knows stuff about you
that seem unbelievably invasive.
Such as when you're pregnant, or where you're
planning to go on holiday.
16.
There have also been allegations that Facebook
automatically scans your private messages
to build up an overall picture of what you're
interested in, so they can show you more accurate
advertisements.
Although Facebook has denied this behaviour,
the astonishing accuracy of their adverts
seems to suggest otherwise.
17.
Even more shocking, there have been cases
of people being murdered because they unfriended
someone on Facebook.
One such case was in 2012 when a couple unfriended
a woman on Facebook, the unfriended woman's
father was so angered by this, that he went
to the couple's house and shot them both.
There was also the shocking case of a woman
who set fire to her friend's house after being
unfriended on Facebook.
18.
Facebook is also responsible for an enormous
amount of divorces.
A frightening study showed that Facebook was
a major contributing factor in up to one-third
of all divorces.
19.
But all this Facebook use may not be as good
for you as you think.
A study suggested that 1 in 3 people feel
more dissatisfied with their lives after visiting
Facebook.
20.
Also a survey showed that 25% of Facebook
users have been dumped on Facebook at one
point and, what's even more worrying, it's
becoming increasingly common for people to
end relationships by simply changing their
Facebook status from "In a relationship."
to "Single".
21.
And finally, there is strong evidence to suggest
that Facebook is dumbing down society.
A study conducted at the Ohio State University
showed that the average grades of students
who use Facebook were a whole grade lower
than students who don't use Facebook.